معنى من كييف يوري ساك مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
سنيوري اولا هل لك ان تؤكد لنا البلدات
والمناطق التي استعادتها القوات
الاوكرانيه حتى الان
اسعدتم مساء
استطيع ان اؤكد بموجب ما قاله هيئه
الاركان
القوات الاوكرانيه الان سيطرنا وطردنا
المحتلين
هذا التين هاتين في قريتان
وعن هذه مجرد بدايه ما الذي يعطي الهجمات
الاوكرانيه زخما هذه المره بتقديرك
لما فهمت سؤالك لكن نحن نقوم منذ فتره
بعمل عمليات تدريب
لفتره طويله من الزمن والان نركزوا على
مساله ازاله القوات المحتله من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه في الشرق حوالي بخموت وفي جبهه
القتال وكما تعوج جبهه القتال مهمه جدا هي
اكثر من 900 كيلومتر طولا ما مدى الاعتماد
في هذا الهجوم على
الاسلحه والمساعدات الغربيه الحديثه التي
قدمت قبل فتره قصيره سيد ساك
طبعا الاسلحه الغربيه التي وصلتنا من
حلفائنا تلعب دورا في غايه الاهميه لان
الاسلحه الغربيه اكثر دقه ولدينا صواريخ
بعيده الماده ولدينا دبابات مزوده بالرؤيه
الليليه والدبابات لديها حمايه درعيه افضل
وبالتالي ايضا لدينا اطلاق صواريخ متعدده
مثل هاي مارس
ومدفعيه معيار 150 وبالتالي كل هذه
الاسلحه استطاعت جنود الاوكرانيين السيطره
واستخدامها بشكل جيد وهي كلها تذكر كجزء
من عملياتنا في الهجوم المضاد هذه مرحله
اولى من التقدم كما اسلفت ما القدره قدره
القوات الاوكرانيه على استعاده زمام
المبادره في هذه الجبهات
نحن نريد ان نكون متفائلين
وسنواصل بدله قصاره جهدنا لتدمير العدو
واذن او اؤكد ان الخلال الايام الماضيه
استمرينا في الحاقه خسائر كبيره على العدو
مثلا في خلال سرعات
مجرما مجرما من روسيا
كانوا على الاوكراني وايضا دمرنا اكثر من
واعداد كبيره من الدبابات والمعدات
العسكريه الروسيه وانظمه المدفعيه ولكن في
الوقت ذاته نفهم
ان
ارهابيين القادمين من روسيا كانت وقت طويل
لبناء خطوط دفاع قويه جدا وبالتالي
المعركه ليست سهله نحن الان نواجه
خطوط دفاعيه ثقيله وقويه جدا ونحن ذلك
بالنظر باعتبار عند التخطيط شكرا لك يوري
ساك مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع في كييف